[Musique]
marius narciso bonjour bonjour c'est
parti vous êtes candidat aux élections
municipales et communautaires à ducos
vous mener la liste on nous semblait
pouvant c'est vous êtes soutenus
notamment en plus de votre mouvement
politique locale par le mime
vous êtes arrivé en seconde position du
premier tour de scrutin le 15 mars en
obtenant 1447 voit ses 27 8 61% des voix
très précisément et cela après sonné
ligne aurélie n'est là et avant lui
marie 7
wilfrid sina et philippe petit vous êtes
donc logiquement maintenu pour au second
tour quelle est tout d'abord votre
lecture des résultats de ce premier tour
alors vous me permettrez monsieur partie
de remercier les électrices et les
électeurs qui m'ont permis justement
d'obtenir ce suffrage et c'est ce qui
fait que je suis là aujourd'hui
alors l'analyse que je fais et les
simples parce que c'est une équipe qui
s'est réalisé dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles avec une crise
sanitaire qui a découragé l'électorat
mais je dis que c'est un résultat qui
est encourageant encourageant parce que
je sais très bien que dans une réalité
qui est difficile parce que vous avez
des candidats qui se tiennent dans un
mouchoir de poche mais vous avez aussi
il faut le dire le meilleur du cos qui
prend une position claire en allant sur
le terrain pour soutenir la candidature
n'est là
donc forcément on sait que les jeux ne
sont pas équitables donc nous avons un
travail à faire sur le terrain
je considère que le résultat que nous
avons obtenu grâce aux électeurs il
n'est plus qu'encourageants essai c'est
ce qui me fait dire qu'aujourd'hui pour
le 28 juin ben nous nous positionnons
dans des perspectives très favorables
c'est ce qui explique votre alliance
avec les candidats qui sont arrivés en
quatrième et cinquième positions
respectivement wilfried sinon directeur
de cabinet numéro son temps et philippe
petit président de l'udps et en
martinique absolument cette alliance n
ai pas fait de manière aléatoire
c'est une alliance qui est fait déjà
dans un état qui est simple c'est
l'intérêt général du coup ce n'est pas
une alliance qui est fait pour bâle
barrer la route à qui que ce soit cette
alliance
elle part du constat c'est que la ville
est dans une situation dramatique
la population est dans une situation de
détresse aujourd'hui il faut mettre
l'expérience
la maturité politique au service de la
commune au service de la ville il faut
être opérationnel immédiatement donc
partant de ce constat nous avons dit
qu'il faut arrêter de se déchirer
il faut aller de la construction il
fallait dans l'apaisement et c'est ce
que nous avons fait et la force que nous
représentons cette force avec cette
alliance qui me met en position
favorable par rapport à mes poursuivants
où reposent sur des atouts c'est quoi
c'est notre capacité à dialoguer à
discuter mais surtout affecté aux
querelles pour nous enrichir nos
différences et aller au delà des
clivages pour mettre en place un projet
commun pour du gosse alors à un moment
donné les querelles et les clivages
seront terminés l'élection aurait lieu
si vous êtes élu maire de ducos quels
projets prioritaires souhaiterais vous
mettre en oeuvre alors c'est vrai que
j'ai présenté un projet à la population
qui qui tourne autour du mieux vivre
ensemble avec comme objectif la famille
les quartiers avec un plan d'action pour
réaliser tout ça à court moyen long
terme mais il faut comprendre bien que
entre ce projet qui a été présenté au
premier tour est aujourd'hui bien la
crise sanitaire est passée par là il y
avait une urgence il y a cette crise
s'est imposée s imposer brutalement
violemment donc il ya des priorités et
parmi ses priorités la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
quand je dis la gestion de la crise
actuelle c'est vraiment ou remettre le
service public en marche pour répondre
aux attentes de la population
ça va commencer par le personnel met le
personnel dans les conditions d'hygiène
et de sécurité
parce que si le personnel n'est pas en
situation de travailler dans les
conditions comme l'exigé la loi et qui
reste dans les obligations d'employeur
nous n'aurons pas le service public
opérationnel ça c'est une chose la
deuxième priorité c'est la rentrée
scolaire de façon inexorable
il faut qu'il y ait une rentrée scolaire
qu'ils soient parfaites mettre les
enfants les enseignants le personnel
encadrant en sécurité pour que justement
cette rentrée se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions
et puis nous avons aussi un autre pan de
la population c'est-à-dire les personnes
âgées les personnes vulnérables
ces personnes qui sont en situation
d'isolement où nous devons effectivement
aller vers ces personnes pour mettre en
place un plan d'accompagnement et vous
comprendrez que on ne peut pas faire
tout ça si on ne prend pas des mesures
pour conforter nos points forts et c'est
pour cela que je dis que ne pourra
positionnement dans l'espace une ça sera
sitôt l'élection de l'espace sud réalisé
faire en sorte que nous puissions
accompagner les entreprises en ont
mutualisé justement toutes les aides que
ce soit de la ctm de la chambre de
commerce l'état l'espace sud pour venir
au chevet de nos entreprises leur
apporter cette bouffée d'oxygène parce
que si ces entreprises qui souffrent je
parle de la sortie de ce confinement
ces entreprises qui souffrent de la
situation parce que nous n'aurons plus
le chômage partiel
donc il faudra anticiper la demande
sociale aussi et faire en sorte que
qu'il y ait un soutien aux entreprises
est un soutien aux personnes en
difficulté voilà je vous remercie
d'avoir participé à cet entretien
réalisé par jean louis gbangbo merci
[Musique]